Hello everybody! My name is Markiplier, and welcome to Firewatch.
What the hell is that? Is that Smokey the Bear?
SMOKEY!
Smoky! Oh god!
Oh jeez.
*Deep voice* HELLO!  HI FRIEND! HOW'S IT GOING!? DEATH ONLY AWAITS YOU  IN HERE!
WATCH OUT FOR FIRES! DON'T BE SWIMMING NAKED WITH FIREWORKS, OR I'LL COME FIND YOU!
[demon laugh, with thunder claps and creepy music getting louder in background]
[music stops] HEH.
Thanks Byrnesy. Your'e always gonna be the best of friends with me!
NNDON'T WORRY! WE'RE ALWAYS GONNA BE FAST FRIENDS! FASTEST OF FRIENDS... HEHEHEHEHUHEHUHE
[Scream]
[Typewriter Keys]
[Floorboards creak]
YOU DO GREAT WRITING IN THE DARKEST OF NIGHTS.
Thanks! God Bernie you're so nice to me!
*Byrnes* I'M NICE TO EVERYONE. CAN'T YOU SEE MY SMILE?!
MY DELIGHTFUL SMILE?!?!!
*intensifies* MY UNENDING SMILE!?!?!?!?!
Okay alright, thanks,
Bernie! I'm 'unna take you with me, you're such a delight. Where did Bernie go?
Where-- Ohohoh, there's Bernie!
YOU THOUGHT I WAS GONE, DID YOU?!
WELL, I CAN NEVER LEAVE!
WE CAN NEVER LEAVE...
*whispering* It's getting dark out...
[Demon Scream]
[Scream]
[fire crackling]
*Markiplier* He's not in here, is he?
BERNIE! BERNIE!!!
Oh god...
Oh no… Bernie no... Bernie no!
WHERE'S BERNIE?
(Distant) Where the hell is Bernie?!
[Scream]
This is not good. This is not good. I can't leave Bernie behind!
You guys may be saying I'm irrational right now,
and that he's a creepy... sign, but he's my friend!
[gasp] BERNIE!! OH GOD!!
[bushes rustle] HEY! HOW YOU DOIN?!
*Mark* I thought I'd lost you! Oh my God!
We gotta go Bernie. We gotta go!
*Bernie* I KNOW. FIRE'S ON THE HORIZON, BUDDY....
[Scream]
Wunderbar!
'Kay, I gotta like, 'kay... DON'T DROP...
[Wind Wooshing]
oh, oh, OH, G– NO!! BERNIE!!!
OH, WHAT THE HELL?!
NO!!!
[guitar music]
*Bernie* Stare into the face of death, and know that all,
lies in the darkness. When fire consumes all, black ash IS ALL THAT WILL REMAIN!!
AND YOU WILL SEE THE DEPRAVITY OF YOUR INSANITY!!!!
*demonic laughter*
[music fades out]
[Fire crackle]
Bernie, tell me what to do!
*Bernie* I DON'T KNOW. MAYBE YOU SHOULD...
DECIDE FOR YOURSELF...
HEHEHEHEHEHE
[silence]
[creaks]
[Sudden combustion]